Se llama "AlterEgo" y es un dispositivo portátil
que proporciona la experiencia de conversar con la IA
que reside en tu mente,
con la que podrías hablar
como si estuvieses hablando contigo mismo, en tu mente.
Hoy presentamos por primera vez en TED el nuevo prototipo.
Y funciona así.
Normalmente, al hablar, el cerebro envía señales neuronales a través de los nervios
a los sistemas internos del habla
para activarlos y hacer que las cuerdas vocales generen el habla:
una de las tareas cognitivas y motrices más compleja
que realizamos los seres humanos.
Ahora bien, imaginen que hablan consigo mismo sin tener que vocalizar,
sin mover la boca ni la mandíbula,
simplemente imaginando las palabras en la mente,
conectando así de forma sutil los sistemas internos del habla,
como la lengua y el paladar.
Cuando esto sucede,
el cerebro envía señales extremadamente débiles
a estos sistemas internos del habla.
AlterEgo cuenta con sensores
insertos en un dispositivo delgado de plástico, flexible y transparente,
que se pega al cuello como una calcomanía.
Los sensores detectan desde la superficie de la piel
esas señales internas que se originan en lo profundo de la cavidad bucal.
Luego, un programa de IA de fondo
intenta descifrar lo que el usuario está tratando de decir.
Después, envía una respuesta al usuario vía conducción ósea,
es decir, sonido que llega al oído a través de los huesos del cráneo
y que el usuario escucha mezclado con los sonidos naturales del entorno
pero sin bloquearlos.
La combinación de todo esto, la entrada, la salida y la IA
brinda una experiencia subjetiva de interacción dentro de tu mente
con la que podrían hablar como si estuviesen hablando con uno mismo.
Una aclaración importante: el dispositivo no graba ni lee tus pensamientos.
Registra información específica que quieres comunicar
por medio de la conexión con los sistemas internos del habla.
Las personas no desean que las lean, sino poder escribir.
Por esta razón diseñamos el sistema
para que registre intencionalmente a partir del sistema nervioso periférico.
Así el usuario siempre tiene el control en todo momento.
Haré una breve pausa para que vean una demostración en vivo.
Voy a hacerle a Eric una pregunta
y él va a buscar esa información
sin vocalizar, sin teclear y sin mover los dedos o la boca.
Tan solo se formulará esta pregunta en su mente.
La IA, entonces, descifrará la respuesta y se la transmitirá a Eric
en forma de audio a través del dispositivo.
Si bien ven una computadora portátil delante de él, no la está usando.
Todo se encuentra dentro del dispositivo.
Solo necesita ese dispositivo para interactuar con la IA y con internet.
Veamos, Eric, ¿cómo está el clima en Vancouver hoy?
Lo que ven en la pantalla
son las palabras que Eric está pensando ahora mismo.
Esto sucede en tiempo real.
Eric: Hace 50º y está lluvioso aquí en Vancouver.
Arnav Kapur: La IA envió la respuesta
en forma de audio a través del dispositivo a Eric.
¿Cuáles serían las implicancias de algo como esto?
Imaginen poder memorizar las cosas de forma exacta,
poder registrar perfectamente la información que piensan,
y luego escucharla cuando la necesiten;
poder buscar información de forma interna
procesando números a la velocidad de una computadora;
enviar mensajes de forma silenciosa a otras personas;
volverte de repente multilingüe
y así pensar en un idioma y escuchar la traducción mentalmente en otro.
Las posibilidades son muchas.
Hay millones de personas en todo el mundo
que tienen dificultades para usar el habla natural:
personas que padecen ELA o esclerosis lateral amiotrófica,
ACV, cáncer de boca, entre muchas otras enfermedades.
Comunicarse les resulta un proceso agotador, lento y muy difícil.
Él es Doug.
Le diagnosticaron ELA hace unos 12 años y desde entonces no es capaz de hablar.
Actualmente, usa un teclado en pantalla
donde puede escribir letras individuales haciendo movimientos con la cabeza.
Le lleva varios minutos formar una sola oración.
Fuimos a visitar a Doug y le preguntamos
cuáles eran las palabras que quisiera comunicar usando nuestro sistema.
Quizá un saludo, como "Hola, ¿qué tal?", o indicar que necesitaba ayuda para algo.
Doug dijo que quería usar nuestro sistema para pedir
que reiniciaran el sistema antiguo que tenía, porque fallaba con frecuencia.
(Risas)
Nunca lo hubiéramos imaginado.
Voy a mostrarles un breve video de Doug usando nuestro sistema por primera vez.
(Voz) Reiniciar computadora.
AK: Lo que acabamos de ver
es cómo Doug se comunica o habla en tiempo real por primera vez
desde que perdió el habla.
Hay millones de personas
que podrían comunicarse en tiempo real, como Doug,
con otras personas, con sus amigos y parientes.
Mi anhelo es poder ayudarlos a expresar sus pensamientos e ideas.
Creo que la computación, la IA e internet
podrían integrarse a nosotros y ser extensiones de la cognición
en lugar de ser entidades externas o adversarios;
podrían amplificar el ingenio humano
dándonos habilidades inimaginables y liberando nuestro verdadero potencial;
y podría quizá incluso liberarnos para ser mejores seres humanos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Shoham Arad: Ven, acércate.
Ven.
Bien.
Quiero hacerte algunas preguntas antes de que desmonten el escenario.
Esto me parece increíble, innovador,
espeluznante, aterrador.
¿Puedes contarnos cuáles son...?
Creo que hay algunos sentimientos negativos sobre esto.
Cuéntanos: ¿puede esto leernos la mente?, ¿podrá hacerlo en cinco años?,
¿podría convertirse en un arma?, ¿cómo luce?.
AK: Nuestro primer principio de diseño, antes de comenzar a trabajar en esto,
fue que las cuestiones éticas no fuesen secundarias.
Así que quisimos introducir la ética en el diseño mismo.
Invertimos el diseño: en lugar de leer directamente el cerebro,
se lee el sistema nervioso somático
que necesariamente debes activar para comunicarte con el dispositivo;
pero aún cuenta con los beneficios de un dispositivo para hablar o pensar.
Tiene lo mejor de ambas áreas.
SA: Creo que la audiencia tendrá muchas otras preguntas.
Dijiste que es una calcomanía, ¿simplemente se ubica allí?
¿Será así la última versión, la apariencia que quieren para el diseño final?
AK: Nuestro objetivo es que la tecnología desaparezca totalmente.
SA: ¿Qué quieres decir?
AK: Si la estás usando, yo no debería darme cuenta.
Nadie quiere la tecnología en el rostro, sino de fondo,
que te amplifique desde el fondo.
Tenemos una versión que se amolda a la piel, que luce como la piel,
pero estamos trabajando en una versión incluso más pequeña que vaya aquí.
SA: Bien, si alguien tiene otra pregunta para Arnav,
estará aquí toda la semana.
Muchas gracias, Arnav.
AK: Gracias, Shoham.